la democracia real quedó instaurada en
hong kong hace 25 años cuando regresó a
la madre patria lo dicho hoy el
presidente chino xi jinping en su visita
a la excolonia para los fastos del
aniversario si también ha felicitado a
los hongkoneses por superar la pandemia
y las protestas violentas de 2019 y ha
defendido tanto el nuevo sistema
patriótico que impide la entrada de los
elementos hostiles a pekín en el
parlamento como la fórmula un país dos
sistemas los críticos sostienen sin
embargo que la ley de seguridad nacional
acabó con aquella fórmula que
garantizaba las libertades y los
derechos de hecho dos años después el
debate es mínimo el parlamento los
medios de comunicación críticos han sido
cerrados y la mayor parte de activistas
y políticos pro democracia han acabado
en la cárcel y en el exilio esta
celebración ha sido bastante diferente a
las anteriores a aquella ley sin las
masivas manifestaciones en las grandes
avenidas porque los escasos grupos
prodemocráticos que quedan renunciaron a
pedir el permiso de manifestación tras
haber recibido la visita de la policía y
también a e investido a john lee el
nuevo jefe ejecutivo de la es colonia
eso sí sin darle la mano por las
precauciones de la pandemia y después ha
regresado a pekín tras el primer viaje
fuera de la china continental en más de
dos años